I don't remember teaming up with a dull dude who went through the sacred waters of the gods,
but I don't remember teaming up with
a boring dude like that.  It's just Tachibana, why is the cutter
saying that tone is good, but
even if I'm sorry, I'm unusual, do
n't press me The man is on the side of the guy who doesn't like discipline
[Music]
Good, good,
last year's movement with a canceller
Rank
Meeee
tan tan
[Music]
[Applause]
Char's comeback is amazing
.
When I spend money,
Pyon le cn I'm a
woman's thunder
What do you say when
I say I'm brandishing a knife?
Smooth it out until it's
like that I'm saying it with my voice, riding on the provocation
These two aren't terribly strong, are they?
I'm going to be
Honjin-san
ana
I'm going to have a
skin
ah ah ah ah
ah ah
dutch Close your eyes during battle Is there someone there?